- It gives me so much hope and praise,
just in life, to bring out blackness
(sign swinging)
- When it comes to Black History month
I like to take a step back,
go back to like the Africanism of it all.
Got my little African
shirt on and whatnot.
Listen to a little bit of afrobeat,
like make me feel
connected to the culture.
- I celebrate resiliency,
to persist through,
and to be an example of
what our people fought for.
- I'm inspired year round by black people.
I love the extraness
that we kinda get during
February that's not seen
the rest of the year.
- I celebrate black culture
and how universal it is
and how similar it is
for all black people.
- Barack Obama, Michelle Obama.
- The Obamas to really exemplify what joy
and excellence looks like.
- We are graced worldwide.
Our culture, our music, our style.
- It's about unity and loving one another.
- I celebrate my father.
Every February he would
have this deck of cards
of influential black
people throughout history.
He would give us a card every day to read,
and he's just tried all
his life to make sure
that we know we're important,
more than just our skin tone.
- For my parents that
had to face adversity
and racism to raise two
half black and half white
kids in the middle of
Arizona in the 1980s.
- My parents who gave
me the life that I have.
- My mom who although
is not African American
has worked her ass off being there for us,
trying to understand
the world that we see.
- Me going natural now
is really from my mother
and her whole outlook on
what it means to be natural
and really just getting
back to the root of it all.
- Everyone who worked
tirelessly to give me everything
I have today.
Rosa Parks, Martin Luther King, Malcolm X
and all those guys that
kind of paved the way
for all of black people.
- Sidney Poitier for
being the first black man
to every win an Oscar.
- I celebrate one of my favorite
activists, Maya Angelou.
One of my favorite quotes is "I've learned
"that people will for get what you said,
"people will forget what you did,
"but people will never forget
how you made them feel."
And that's something that I
try to carry with me every day.
- I celebrate the music that
has come out of black history.
- The Temptations, Aretha Franklin.
- Miles Davis and Muddy Waters
and guys that changed the game.
- Sister Rosetta Tharpe, Billy Holiday,
and Jimi Hendrix.
- Bob Marley.
I will say, in the year 2016.
- You don't need an occasion
to celebrate Beyonce.
You always celebrate Beyonce.
- Jay-Z.
- Solange.
- Kendrick Lamar.
- Change the Rapper was my shit.
- Chance is an incredible artist,
an incredible father,
ultimately one of the
leaders of our generation.
- Spike Lee represents
for the black culture,
does it in such a
beautiful way through film.
- Moonlight. One of the
most incredible films
of our generation.
I think the conversations
about what we believe
blackness and black
masculinity to look like
was really important.
Celebrating blackness in a way that's
like really elevating the conversation.
- We weren't pigeon-holed and
put into these little roles
and just made to be side
characters or supporting cast.
- And I really cannot like
leave out black women, you know.
Black women and what
they've done for culture
and what they're doing for us.
- Finding strength and being
recognized for their beauty
and their talent and their hard work.
I'm inspired by women of
color who are taking strides
behind the camera as
directors and producers,
and also those women who
are in front of the camera
and showing us this
dynamic and diverse world
that we live in.
- [All] That's what I celebrate.
(calm music)